hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master dynamo 63 Aleksei right and
x equals mania there are there's more
than one Guzman he is an excellent
addition affiky only recently published
a book out on the window past the the
side set variation yeah this is not such
a bad line for black either but why what
how is it played forgot about it some
bishop is 3 business Bishop e3 92 94
something like that I I remember Bishop
e6 and okay 97-92 we should be 623 sm is
the line because night c4 actually
blunders Bishop takes h2 so if he goes
97 I have to play Queen c3 first if I
remember this correctly 97-94 bishop
edge to take stakes on default takes on
c4 it's a funny trick
[Music]
oh okay yes forgotten close a bottle
maybe s4 not in his his theory here but
97 looks extremely natural or maybe I'm
confusing stuff with it very much
possible it's not something that I play
every day and Nancy for looks or queen
c3 to play Nancy for looks very standard
I don't threaten to take on the
six-bedroom t1 is a little bit annoying
[Music]
if he goes be five maybe night a five in
[Music]
ok so M group Tijuana this may be
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know taking too long here for
normal moves so if i take this now and
then queen-to-be form may be a bit
unnatural looking good okay it did sorry
[Music]
so very much playable you see doing
there Queen g7 it's not a very
comfortable looking move we should have
for maybe now it's a bit awkward it's a
bit awkward yeah but I can take b7 em or
not at all or Bishop c5 actually this is
interesting let's check the spaceship c5
route d7 194 you Oh huh this is getting
getting interesting um okay and if i
take this is also just good takes and
now Bishop c5 right
it's not doing that much okay I'm kind
of going back and forth in
[Music]
hmm it doesn't feel like I did this
right I could have cared I could have
checked and B 3 maybe 4 96 okay maybe
that's five no he just attacks d 1
huh that's a good
somehow still
maybe it everything here this is
actually threatening night f5 because
the groupon d8 is hanging at least I
think it's a threat hey this is thread
95 oops why isn't that working ok show
me it basically forced me to do it maybe
that's a miracle line here I can take on
d 297 king of seven but I cannot believe
it ok ok but i have ninety-seven right
[Music]
can also check on g5 Luke 697 that
doesn't win actually that's a bit a bit
amazing but it doesn't win check this is
probably correct and let's see here and
take CH it takes my queen that's no good
I can take c5 this one yeah I should do
this and I should do it somewhere
quickly I have much more time also so
see for all right time morning who's
going tonight f4 here right that's crazy
crazy but I can take em yeah for good
good game I can take on edge 5 simply
the night is completely completely off
side
I just got f5 him it's a little bit
annoying so let's do this you cannot
take c4 as then I have G find a trap
tonight yeah so why is defending well
here defending well and I cannot take on
every five I thought I can take on f5
I'm stupid it was a stupid stupid way to
claim check Oh gras Alfred Gras a third
drum out wrong yeah Justin Moore anjum
that was such a totally winning position
and was quite happy actually I with how
I Plato's and then then Allah some our
hair let him escape here from this from
this terrible position hmm so let's see
roop t2 was good yeah and I mean this is
just and he basically says here to do it
here at seven and now Quincy fun if why
am I not just winning Knight takes wins
I cannot take with the rook gammy
looking at the i'm looking at f8 ah no
it's just so simple this this end
resides came yeah yeah this is not so
easy and that was completely banking on
the f5 now okay i actually panicked here
I just f4 was it was irritating Mia but
I can just play be three of course
therefore whatever I
go here and he still is completely lost
I'm just just very badly barely plated
yeah actually miscounted I thought I was
still a pawn off but it can't yeah we
just have a dead position oh ok thanks
for watching